[Musique]
la manière
ainsi qu une chose est
[Musique]
j'ai été père showman j'ai vu servir
pour tenir le micro et je suis et
théâtre et secondaire puisque le tapis
rouge à pépé mais j'ai préféré à des
caméras
en trois ans les crocs et j'ai appris
mais l'excès du son
à tout et qu'ils sont
[Musique]
m
affirmer qu'on a sauté dans la mer
j'aimais quand la partie chercher 6e 4
il faut faire le film avec nous
[Musique]
ben j'ai plutôt aimé le tournage parce
que on n'arrivait pas à l'eau dit avoir
j'ai fini
on
[Musique]
le projet viennent l'équipe d'enfants
différents pour aller chercher les
autres est pas l inclusion quand on a
tendance à l'avoir au quotidien dans la
société c'est à dire la société dit
comme ordinaire qui n'a pas de problème
va prendre les élèves porteurs
d'handicap en actu diola c'est nous ce
qu'on veut montrer dans ce collège et on
veut montrer vraiment on assiste là
dessus les compétences de mots négatifs
déjà ils ont plein de compétences et
voilà on s'intéresse pas à leur handicap
on s'intéresse à ce qu'ils sont capables
de faire voilà ce qu'il faut c'est le
message qu'on veut porter à apporter
notre savoir faire et leurs compétences
et leur savoir faire un film c'est alors
seulement les élèves ballot c'est pour
démontrer aux jeunes
enfin les jeunes de notre génération que
la sienne mais c'est pas quelque chose a
rigolé dessus et que ça peut entraîner
des situations vraiment en danger
enlevez la pression'' harmonique
[Musique]
beaucoup de choses puisqu'il ya la
partie animation déjà que les élèves ne
connaissent pas du tout donc on va faire
venir un professionnel donc ils vont
découvrir un métier
ensuite la partie tournage où là c'est
encore une autre
notre axe et après il y aura la partie
montage où on va faire de l'initiation
donc il ya beaucoup de rôles et de
métiers différents finalement qui vont
début j'ai appris des nouveaux trucs
plus l étape de scénario comment
être dans hérold personnages pour créer
son propre scénario il faut toujours que
ça soit présent tourner sous la pluie
sous des grosses averses
il y a eu des l'actrice mme al qui
n'étaient pas là donc on avait trouvé
une doublure la dernière minute n'est
pas mal de galères comme on dit et puis
du coup ça les a soudés énormément et
puis aussi ce qui les a sauvés c'est le
fait qu'ils ont dû faire jouer des
retraites virant comme les acteurs
on était assis techniciens aussi bien
aux sons la caméra pourrait bien là
aujourd'hui font de montage
il est une eric en même temps il ya eu
aussi de la musique
[Musique]